when I did the first one I had no plans
for sequel was a standalone phone that I
started getting interested in doing a
sequel because I had just seen how much
film technology had advanced it's a
whole new world and we couldn't have
done 20 years ago what we didn't
indepence the researchers we used their
technology strengthen our planet but it
won't be enough technology is a lot more
advanced now I think that was part of
the reason you know Roland felt like now
was the time I have seen movies on imax
the last movie i saw where I really was
blown away was interstellar and that's
when I kind of said to everybody who
have to do a high-res version of
defensive researchers Oh
they build the White House in the movie
in and all of the effects everyone was
just like wow well hold on cuz its back
and it's bigger and badder and older
than ever it's gonna come at you in full
force I decided to do it in 3d mainly
because we have nearly 2,000 visual
effects shots we have scenes which I
think when you see them in 3d on imax
will blow your mind it's the right way
to do it we never had a chance we didn't
last time either this is meant to be big
and on roland emmerich makes a big movie
it's a big big spectacle oh my god we're
gonna see it on imax and 3d I can't wait
I think that'll be good would be fun oh
my movies are really meant anyway for
the big screen and imax is the biggest
scream and to get the most out of it and
on top of it the sound and I max screen
it's probably the best in the world I
mean there's no comparison imax is the
perfect place to say this film
absolutely it's big in epic and imax is
only gonna make it better so forth of
july so let's show them some fireworks
you